alma Sam haré prepara su maleta hace
parte del grupo de palestinos a quienes
Arabia Saudita Les regaló el viaje para
realizar la peregrinación a la Meca el
Hash
el sentimiento de alegría inexplicable
estoy extremadamente feliz soy una madre
orgullosa de un mártir Y ahora él hizo
posible que yo visite la cava He estado
esperando este día Durante los últimos
17 años
alza perdió a su hijo en casa Durante
los ataques de 2006 cada año desde hace
más de 10 años el reino Saudita paga el
viaje a milpales chinos que han sufrido
directamente las consecuencias del
conflicto con Israel como familias de
Mártires o prisioneros un vilal también
fue elegido
tengo sentimientos encontrados tanto de
alegría como de tristeza estamos tristes
porque Israel Sigue reteniendo los
cuerpos de nuestros hijos no podemos
verlos y no sabemos dónde están y
estamos felices de que Arabia Saudita
nos haya concedido esta ayuda por el
bien de nuestros hijos y nos haya
elegido para ello les damos las gracias
a ellos al rey al pueblo y al gobierno
algunas veces los musulmanes deben
esperar años antes de poder hacer la
peregrinación Ameca debido a la gran
demanda de fieles de todo el mundo el
Hash es uno de los cinco pilares del
islam todo musulmán que tenga la
capacidad física y financiera de hacerlo
debe cumplirlo al menos una vez en la
vida a rabia Saudita recibí alrededor de
12 mil millones de dólares al año por
esta peregrinación